tu aimes ça
ok St
Rec
ok ça traîne ouais je ne vois pas vraiment
grand chose avec l'exposition c'est peut-être aller
à la roue de la crasse
un le mauvais Pays de Galles je
pense oh cool ok trois
L ralentis la vitesse de l'air je veux
descendre à 40 40 40  les
nœuds sont ceux-là W et bien je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
peuvent
être là, je pense qu'ils le sont parce qu'ils ont
un gros appartement ouais donc ils
me la tête les
roues bhead tu as l'ex rallonge euh non je
ne l'ai pas pour le
moment  voyons quoi, qu'est-ce qu'on en est à 1
D4 euh pourquoi le polariseur peut-être ouais peut-être peut-être que je suis d'accord,
arrête d'enregistrer
un instant, je vais tourner le polariseur
un peu, je vais sortir,
ils ont raison, ils ont raison, je peux
toujours  voir l'anneau L'anneau je les vois
aussi ok il n'y en a que deux gardes le bas je
peux je peux les voir sous l'eau là-
bas ouais les voilà ils remontent
oh tu fais des bulles tu as
ça ouais je l'ai je'  je l'ai,
laisse-les
tomber
Oh, je fais des
bulles, je ne sais pas où ils
sont par rapport à ce Bub, il y a, il y a,
je peux le voir là, je peux
les voir sous
l'eau, ok,
ok, ils pêchent, parfois ils font
des bulles dans un  sonnez pour arrondir le poisson,
quelle hauteur sommes-
nous 2, vous voulez descendre, à quelle hauteur allons-
nous
descendre, allons-nous quitter le niveau de vol
130 momentanément au-dessus de notre tête dans 12 minutes, en
regardant d'abord à
15 heures, juste à
5 heures, je vais jouer  avec un
polariseur ici parce que ça s'améliore, c'est
plus lumineux, pouvez-vous toujours les voir
oui, je oui, je peux, ils sont au milieu en
bas du cadre juste au-dessus du
code temporel, un peu près, il y en
a juste
là quelques-uns non je suis  je ne suis pas sûr que
nous puissions
bien les perdre, c'était inhabituel, nous sommes
derrière eux ici à droite, ici à droite,
vous le voyez, ok, regardez en arrière,
regardez en arrière, à droite, à droite ou à gauche du
scintillement, euh, à droite, à gauche du
scintillement.
ouais, descendons peut-être plus lentement ou
descendons ouais, tiens-le là, tiens-le
là oh
sympa
wow il est toujours
là avec la queue regarde regarde maintenant ouais
j'ai la queue juste un animal je pense
qu'il n'a pas vraiment fait grand-chose
non, pas maintenant, regardez par l'autre
fenêtre les gars ouais, je pense qu'ils sont
plus là, il est juste
là oh ouais je les vois à 15h00 15h00 ouais
ouais, ils sont
énormes oh mon Dieu, ils sont vraiment énormes, regarde
ça  vous pouvez vraiment les voir en
essayant de ralentir la vitesse,
s'il vous plaît, je ne peux pas ralentir très bien,
je ne peux pas vraiment le voir dans
le peut-être, faire comme un cercle de plus
et cela pourrait être bien ouais, est-ce que vous
les comprenez ouais, pas bien pour le
moment  non je ne peux pas les voir je ne peux pas
les voir continue de regarder de l'autre côté
oh ils sont là-bas à
14h00 sur ta droite je pense que je les ai
ouais ouais tu les as
je pense que je ne pense pas  ils vont
particulièrement
loin dans mon ascension de niveau,
je suis à toi
ouais ok tu l'as
toujours en train, est-ce qu'on est hein euh
quel Focus il y a il y a
l'autre derrière eux
ouais l'autre est derrière ok en
fait ok euh encore un de plus  un
toi pour un autre
Circle
Shadow, c'est un peu un
cadeau, je pense qu'ils sont toujours là
quelque part en plein milieu, non,
juste à 14h00 à 14h00
ouais, je les ai perdus, je ne les ai pas vus
pendant un moment, je pense qu'ils sont à
14h00, nous avons de bons clichés, de
toute façon, d'accord, il est
14h00,
encore un gars du Cercle non non, je les ai perdus ouais, je les ai
perdus oh non non non juste
là à gauche du scintillement  ouais euh ouais et
bien maintenant dans le scintillement dans le
scintillement, laisse passer le tle passe ouais nous sommes
Flying Blind maintenant mais d'accord, nous avons
de très bons clichés ici,
essayons-en un de plus et puis
ouais à 1:00  à gauche 13h00 à gauche pour celui-
ci
2h00 à droite tu penses qu'ils sont
là, ils sont là ouais, fais-les se
retourner, se retourner vers
nous, il n'y en a qu'un, je ne sais pas où
les autres
sont allés, oh, c'est l'autre  vraiment loin,
ok, ouais, j'ai
très bien fini,
ok, ok, allons dans l'autre sens, nous sommes
censés aller
ouais, il y a le
dérapage [Musique] de toute façon, allons
[Musique]
ouvrir à fond, je le fais
là, le HP
BS sur le  à droite
o00
de quel côté se trouve celui-là,
ils vont bien deux d'entre
eux deux d'entre eux vous en
avez deux vous en avez trois en fait sur votre
écran où est le troisième un au
milieu 1 deux
trois je ne peux pas voir le troisième non  l'
autre est euh sous l'eau en fait
ok
ça doit être une plongée profonde tu as la
queue ouais j'ai la queue ouais oui
peux-tu voir autre chose
qu'après que la queue soit partie non ils sont tous
sous l'eau en ce moment
ok
ils sont toujours sous
l'eau  Je pense qu'ils sont dans le scintillement mais
euh
non,
ils ne sont toujours pas
sortis, casquette blanche ici, ce qui rend un
peu délicat
ouais,
d'accord, nous sommes au milieu de la mer et
nous ne les revoyons
plus, d'accord, devrions-
nous continuer  ça
va ok arrête d'
enregistrer c'était juste dans le euh c'est un
gros grosse
maman oh continue à venir juste
là, il y a sa queue
il a plongé est-il un TA ouais il a
plongé et il est di G ok il Di
ok trop
tard au revoir au
revoir ok arrête  enregistrement